you've got to be kidding me only 2.75
watts of charging speed is apple's
magsafe battery pack a flop
well today we have a bunch of tools here
i have a wattage tester multiple phones
some third-party battery packs
we will be taking a look and finding out
just that
in my last video we looked at the specs
that apple didn't publish on the main
product page
which led me to believe that this thing
isn't going to be as nice as it should
for the price tag
i have to say that the build quality
looks and feels fantastic
i probably have the most detailed
wireless charging pack
test video on my channel and none of
those
really came close to this so it
definitely feels really
nice now inside the box not only do we
not have
a charging brick we don't even have a
charging cable
do you wish they put that in because
every other one that i've purchased
did come with one let's see how well it
holds on
i'm gonna attach it to my 12 pro max at
first
and okay first off the magnet is pretty
dang
powerful that is really nice but
unfortunately as far as
spinning just like with apple's wallet
it spins fairly easily and then applying
a little bit too much pressure
it does pop off so as far as the
connection
it doesn't feel as strong as i thought
it might feel
and it's really do you hear that medium
yeah that secondary little click it's
almost like this pad
is separate from it almost like it's a
little magsafe section there
that's moving that's really really weird
now let's see if it's any better
with an iphone 12 that has the glossy
back um
not really doesn't really seem that way
all right now let's see how it compares
to the hyper power this thing's about 40
bucks is it
a part of my ultimate test the hyper
power is fairly slick
okay so apples is a little bit more
powerful as far as the magnets slightly
more grippy but not by
much and my favorite one right over here
this thing is
28 oh my goodness okay
look at that this one basically has a
rubber pad at the bottom
and it stays on there super well
barely twists and barely moves that's
crazy the smaller one
is actually better now i did buy anker's
wireless power pack that's probably the
most popular third-party option and it's
less than half the price of apples
so i will be doing a very in-depth
comparison
between these so go ahead and hit that
subscribe button below if you guys want
to check that out and that also will
help us reach our goal
of 1 million subscribers before the end
of the year we would greatly appreciate
it now before we see what shows up on
the screen let's try it out on the mini
as you guys can see it fits perfectly
and as far as grip still slides around
just way too easy for my liking
so footprint size it's about the same as
the hyper power actually
slightly longer if you guys see that it
is a little bit thinner but compared to
blue mini
you guys see this thing is quite a bit
smaller footprint
size now let's check out the thickness
it's actually
right about the same thickness as blue
mini
but compared to the hyper power it is
quite a bit thinner now as far as
comfort in the hand it feels
surprisingly
good and it doesn't feel as slick as i
expected
pretty much the same slickness as just
the regular back
and compared to the regular iphones it
is more slick than that glass
glossy back and now let's test out the
charging let's attach it
as we look at the screen there we go we
have the little animation
and it looks like is it dead yeah we're
not getting any charge
let's go to our widget over here this is
one of the benefits of getting apple's
version actually shows up
yeah it is completely dead but with that
let's move on to our next test
and see how fast this thing can charge
i have my wattage meter here i'm gonna
plug it into apple's 20 watt power
adapter
and let's take a look here and it looks
like it's jumping between
15 to 15.25 i usually go off of the
lower
amount so that's pretty decent you
should get a fairly quick charge with
this now i will be talking about that
in my full review and how long it takes
to charge up both this way and with
reverse
wireless charging but our blue mini
right here will actually accept
16.7 watts so this actually charges
a little bit faster now apple says that
you can use this as
a magsafe wireless charging pad so you
don't actually have to buy
a separate one and this is the perfect
scenario where it's dead
but i want to charge my phone so let's
go ahead and connect this
and take a look at that it actually
bumped up the wattage to about 16.5
16.85 so it is
actually working as a mac safe charger
actually slightly higher
than what you need so maybe actually
slowly charging the internal battery as
well
so yes it does in fact work as a magsafe
wireless charger which typically costs
you 40 bucks
now my next question is how much of that
wattage
is actually passing through to our phone
let's see how efficient apple's magsafe
option is
compared to the alternatives i'm gonna
go ahead and run
this test which will actually test the
real world wattage that is hitting our
iphone's battery pack
all right we have our results and we
achieved 9.21
watts that actually hit our iphone's
battery
so that is not the full 15 watts of
course there is some performance
loss through wireless so let's go ahead
and test out how this compares
to actually buying apple's mac safe
charger and using that instead and it
looks like we do
have a difference using a standard max
safe wireless charger we got 12.66 watts
that hit the battery so that is a
difference of roughly
40 percent so no apple's max safe
battery pack
does not charge your phone as fast even
if you're using it as a wireless
charging pad alright guys take a look
at this i just connected it to the
iphone 12
and in the widgets it's showing that the
backsafe battery pack is already at half
capacity
so this is very interesting we did cut
the cameras
uh we transferred some of clips so it
was more than just a few minutes of
charging but what do you say between
roughly
half hour or so and it's half charged
so maybe the actual capacity in here is
very low
but it's just super efficient and that's
something we're going to talk about and
test
in our full review now since it's half
charged the next thing that i want to
test
is how fast can this pack charge your
phone
when you don't have it plugged in this
is the biggest reason i wanted to buy
apple's version
over the third-party alternatives these
don't use magsafe they just use
the alignment magnets i want a much
faster option but based on the specs
we were disappointed so let's go ahead
and open up our app
and give it a test now i'm running it on
the iphone 12 app
is also running on the 12 pro max and
the 12 mini
to see if we have a difference depending
on what phone you own
and it looks like we have 4.18
watts so yes it is true that
once you have it unplugged from the wall
not using as a
wired wireless charger you do not get
magsafe speeds
it's apple rated at 5 watts in their
support page which is a letdown
in reality we're getting 4.18 a little
bit less that is actually hitting the
battery
now that is still better than the 3.5 of
this
blue mini but it is 28 bucks and the
actual capacity
is likely about the same as apples we'll
be testing that
um a but this 40 hyper power
this thing will actually charge at 7
watts that hits the battery so
even faster when you're using it as it's
intended
now i'm testing the iphone 12 pro max
we'll see if it can do any better
but what i'm really curious about is the
12 mini
you've got to be kidding me only 2.75
watts of charging speed i don't know
what is going on we just saw
4.18 or so with iphone 12
i do feel a good amount of heat on the
back of the magsafe battery pack right
here more so than before
so maybe it is tapering down but let's
go ahead and take it off
uh maybe just let it sit for a sec and
i'm gonna test it out on the iphone 12
mini all right that is what i'm talking
about
4.96 watts now it's still not 15 or
12 and a half like max safe should be
but we are getting the full
five right now that apple advertises so
maybe that was because
the battery cooled down a little bit and
this phone was cool
um it's actually getting that full
amount which actually means that they're
feeding more than five they must be
feeding
at least six or maybe six and a half to
be able to achieve this five
but you can add that now this phone is
actually a little bit lower battery as
well it was about 68
percent when it started so maybe there's
some tapering also going on if you're
just above 70
we will find out that in our full review
and also
how much heat affects it because as you
guys saw with the 12 pro max
it was not doing well at all and that
could be because of
longevity apple doesn't want to run it
too hot so it might taper it down
but then if you're doing something like
gaming and you have the screen on
there's a potential that your phone can
actually drop in battery
even though you have it attached if
you're doing something
like gaming so we will be looking into
that so let's get back to our original
question is apple's magsafe battery pack
a flop
well kind of we did find out some
positive things about it
such as how fast it charges at least
based on what we saw
and that it is thinner and a little bit
lighter than i
expected but also some negatives like if
you're using it
as a wireless charging base station it
doesn't give you the full
performance and it is capped at that
five
watts of charging and of course it is
expensive
and it potentially could even thermal
throttle or slow down
to stop it from getting too hot which in
turn
will mean that it will last a lot longer
than some of these third-party options
but at the same time it's a hundred
bucks compared to 40
or compared to 28. now this one that's
also rated five watts it will charge at
3.5
but this one that's rated at 7.5 charges
at
seven and it has a larger capacity as
well
so the last thing that we have to answer
is how much of
your iphone can this thing actually
charge
and how fast can it do it so that'll be
the final answer
before that i'm gonna have to spend a
couple days of doing some detailed tests
and then give you guys
my full review and along with that you
know this gives you reliable cells
you know it's going to last a long time
it's going to work but of course we have
anchors that we will be doing a
head-to-head comparison against
and you know you can trust anchor as
well so make sure you guys click that
circle above to subscribe if you guys
want to see that video
and check out the other ones that i've
done right over here
this max and i'll see you in the next
[Music]
video
[Music]